Okay Michael, I have two quizzes for you. Okay?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Here's the first quiz, and here's the way it's set up.
I want you to fill in the empty boxes of this table. Okay?
>> Ooh.
>> Got it.
>> There's a lot of empty boxes.
>> Okay, but Okay, let me make sure I understand what's going
on here. So we're looking at
three different algorithms that are learning algorithms.
>> Yep.
>> There's one One neural net
>> No
>> Okay, one nearest neighbor.
>> Mm-hm
>> K nearest neighbor and linear regression.
>> Yep
>> And for each one you want to know running time and space.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And this is on n points I assume, yeah, n
sort, what does it mean for data points to be sorted?
>> So let's assume we're living in a world where all
of our data points are you know in r one. Okay.
>> Oh okay that well that. That could be sorted.
>> That could be. Yeah that could be
sorted. And that you know we are going to be
out putting some real numbers as well. So they're points on a, on a number line.
So to make things simple for you. I'm going to
say that the points that your given are already sorted.
>> Oh ok alright. And yeah that makes sense. Its just
a scaler. So then a query point is going to come in.
And then its going to be some value. And were going to have
to find the nearest neighbor or do the linear regression or whatever.
>> Right.
>> Alright now that's for running time. For
now space your talking about the space of what.
>> How much space you are going to have
to do in order to accomplish your task. How much space
you going to have to use in order to accomplish your task?
>> So this is kind of like the the. The
space that's representing the class enviro. Or the regression. After training.
>> Yes. So actually that question
about after training is important. You'll notice
I've divided each of these algorithms
into two phases. There's the learning phase.
How much time it takes to learn. How much space you need to
learn. Then there's the query phase. When I give you some new value and
you have to output and answer. What's the running time for that
and what are the space requirements for that? Okay? You got that?
>> Yeah
>> I want that for each one. Of these three algorithms.
>> Except for one nearest neighbor which the, it appears
as though you filled in for me to get me started.
>> Right so just to get you started and make it easier for you know
to know what I'm talking about. I'm talking about big o times here. Right. I'm
not going to make you write out big o. Big o is implicit. So if we
look at one nearest neighbor, and we
ask well what's the running time of learning?
Well, it's constant. Right? Because there's no learning.
>> I see. You just take that sorted set of data
points and you just pass it along through the query here.
>> Right. Now, you could say that" Well, I'm going to
take the data points or I'm going to copy them into this
database," and so it's linear. But let's assume they already come in
a data base, or some data structure that you can use, okay?
>> Gotcha.
>> Okay, so now that actually brings us
to a nice little question about how much space,
learning takes here. And, well because you have to store those points,
and keep them around. The space requirements are big O of N.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> Okay, good. So given that as an example. Do
you think your one example in your data base. Mm, do
you think you can use that to build up labels
for all the rest of the phases of the different algorithms?
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> Okay, cool. Go for it.